hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
advancing towards personalized medicine
in lung cancer
a focus on gene rearrangement testing
i am sabrina lemoos of lab roots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by
abbott scientific affairs molecular
diagnostics
learn more visit dot
molecular.abbott.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow that process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker dr
yelina eskina the global
scientific affairs manager at abbott
molecular
for complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen elena you may
now begin your presentation
thank you sabrina and thank you everyone
for joining me
and listening to my presentation on
advancing towards personalized medicine
and lung cancer a focus on gene
rearrangement testing
these are my disclosures and i would
like to
start by talking about the fact that
identifying specific
biomarkers associated with specific
types of cancer has become a driving
force
in the advancement of personalized
medicine and there have been various
technologies developed in order to do so
gene rearrangements are a prime example
of such biomarkers
having been identified as a common
genetic alteration
that can be targeted by various
therapeutics especially in non-small
cell lung cancer
therefore identifying the presence of
gene rearrangements
is the objective of various companion
diagnostic assays
this review will focus on the emerging
technologies to identify gene
rearrangements
specifically focusing on alk and roth1
and non-small cell lung cancers
i will provide a technical overview of
the methodologies associated
with identifying gene rearrangements
including a review
of the various guidelines and
recommendations
the common practices and the
difficulties associated with testing
and finally discuss the best course of
action that can be taken
through the patient's treatment cycle
but first i would like a quick review of
the global statistics
surrounding lung cancer in 2018
lung cancer was designated as having the
highest number of
incident cases and deaths globally
non-small cell lung cancer makes up 80
to 85 percent of all lung cancer cases
with a majority being adenocarcinoma
type
the five-year overall survival rate of
non-small cell lung cancer is
approximately 24
while the five-year metastatic lung
cancer survival is as low as six percent
in general there have been limited
therapy options when it comes to
non-small lung cancer
prior to 2009 chemotherapy was still
thought as the best course of
treatment for patients with advanced
non-small cell lung cancer
and in 20 2006 epidermal growth factor
receptor
inhibitors like eshitnib were considered
novel agents
for second line therapy without a clear
definition of which
egfr abnormality was critical
but in 2007 the fusion between the
anaplastic lymphoma kinase
and nl4 genes was identified in lung
cancer
and the result of the fusion between the
two genes was a protein with increased
tyrosine kinase activity
this fusion protein and its increased
activity could be considered a potential
target
for non-small cell lung cancer therapy
in 2009
the american society of clinical
oncology released guidelines
for stage four non-small cell lung
cancer with the following
recommendations
that kidsidnib could be used as
first-line therapy for stage four
non-small cell lung cancer patients
that had an activating egfr mutation yet
the guideline
still stated that there was insufficient
evidence to recommend
routine use of molecular markers instead
use of molecular markers was supported
to obtain a more accurate histologic
classification of the disease
or for investigational purposes
but in 2010 the use of a new tyrosine
kinase inhibitor qrizopnip
was shown to be associated with
increased survival of non-small cell
lung cancer patients
with tumors positive for alk gene
rearrangement
and in 2011 the fda concurrently
approved
pfizer's velcori an abba and abbott's
vices alk break apart fish probe kit
being the first example of a
co-development of a companion diagnostic
with the associated therapeutic this led
to the college of american pathologists
the international association for the
study of lung cancer
and the association for molecular
pathology
to increase to release the first
molecular testing
guidelines for non-small cell lung
cancer in 2013.
here they define the best practices in
molecular testing
for therapy selection and advanced
non-small cell lung cancer patients
specifically recommending that testing
patients for egfr mutations using
pcr-based technology
to select them for gesitnib and other
egfr tyrosine kinase inhibitors
and testing for alka gene rearrangements
using a dual break apart fish probe
to select patients for chromosome
tyrosine kinase inhibitor therapy
with the possibility that an alk ihc
test
if carefully validated could be
considered as a screening methodology
for selecting specimens for follow-up
fish confirmatory testing
in 2014 asco issued follow-up guidelines
which reaffirmed
the cap iaslc and amp guidelines
and added the recommendation that if an
institution is not using
an fda-approved assay then they should
develop a specific testing algorithm
and that ihc could be used as a
screening method
followed by the fda approved vices alk
test for confirmation
by 2018 ros1 was added as the third
molecular target
to be considered mandatory for testing
for targeted therapy selection
with more potential targets being
discussed and studied for potential
therapy selection
all three of these biomarkers have an
effect on downstream signaling
specifically on cell growth and
proliferation
and at the diagnostic level they can
provide predictive and prognostic
information which is why we should take
a closer look at these tyrosine kinase
receptors or receptor tyrosine kinases
which are cell membrane proteins that
act as signal transduction
regulators make up each our egfr
alk and roth ones along to this group
these are
activated when the cell surface receptor
binds to specific
signaling molecules known as ligands
which activate the tyrosine kinase
domain
thus sending signals that affect cell
proliferation
differentiation migration and apoptosis
abnormalities in these proteins can
result in deregulated tyrosine kinase
activities
leading to unregulated cellular activity
but at the same time these proteins can
be targeted by tyrosine kinase
inhibitors
and when there is a specific inhibitor
targeting a specific protein
the outcome is personalized therapeutic
being able to identify a genetic
abnormality affecting the tyrosine
kinase receptor
is key to determining the appropriate
action to take
in blocking the abnormal activity for
instance
egfr is known to have specific mutations
while gene amplifications are commonly
associated with the met receptor
tyrosine kinase
but the genetic abnormality we will
focus on today is gene rearrangements
as this one has been identified to be
the most common abnormality
associated with both alk and roth1 gene
in general chromosome rearrangements are
not uncommon
and have been categorized as
demonstrated here as inversions
duplications
solutions and translocations
but the overarching point is that when
specific genes are involved
they can result in abnormal fusions
between the regulatory elements of one
gene
with a coding region of another gene if
the involved genes are receptor tyrosine
kinases
then it is possible that the tyrosine
kinase portion of the gene
can be fused with a regulatory region of
its fusion partner
resulting in a chimeric protein with
constitutively
activated tyrosine kinase basically a
tyrosine kinase protein that does not
require activation
by signaling molecules
in non-small cell lung cancer the first
gene rearrangement was identified as
being between alk and elm-4 gene
but soon after other partners were
identified
these rearrangements result in
constitutive
activation of the alpha tyrosine kinase
activity
which could then be targeted by a
tyrosine kinase inhibitor
such as chrosatnip an interesting aspect
to keep in mind when it comes to alkgine
rearrangements
is that the break point region of alk
appears to be consistently at or near
the transom
transmembrane portion of the gene
leaving room for variability in the
resulting fusion gene
that is it can have variation in the
cellular localization
and level of expression
and when it comes to that variability
according to the atlas of genetics and
cytogenetics
and oncology and hematology there have
been over 50 fusion partners identified
for the alk gene
of course not all of these occur in
non-small cell lung cancer
but variations of those partnerships and
more partners continue to be revealed
besides alks there is another gene that
has been shown to be associated with
non-small cell lung cancer
and it is also a receptor tyrosine
kinase
the human c-roth oncogene 1 or
roth1 has structural similarities to
other
receptor tyrosine kinase proteins like
alk
without it is also has equal tamology
which allows it to be targeted by the
same tyrosine kinase inhibitors such as
cresotnit
but unlike alks bronze 1 is normally
expressed in many tissues such as
kidneys
the cerebellum peripheral neural tissues
the stomach the small intestine
and the colon the rearranged gene was
first identified in 1987 in glioblastoma
and a fusion partner was identified in
2003
but it wasn't until 2007 when riccova
and associates identified roth1 gene
rearrangement and non-small cell lung
cancer
like although one has been associated
with over 25 partner genes
and in many tissue types in some cases
only being identified in one patient
so how can biomarkers be identified so
that appropriate decisions
can be made at the care of the patient
in general there are various methods to
identify biomarkers
one can detect the presence of the gene
or genetic abnormality
using cytogenetics and
psychohybridization such as
fish fish or kish
sequencing such as sanger sequencing and
next generation sequencing
or polymerase chain reaction
amplification
pcr or rtpcr another approach
is to identify the actual product of the
abnormality
this typically involves using antibodies
targeting the product
via ihc or elisa methodology
there are also other methodologies such
as flow cytometries and various
microarrays
but when it comes to identifying gene
rearrangements
the best approach has not yet been
decided
initially there were three main methods
used
to identify alpha gene rearrangements in
non-small cell lung cancer
there was fish ihc and pcr
amplification fish is looking at the
gene patterns
it is looking for the presence or or the
absence of a gene
or the relative location of the gene and
individual cells
in the case of alk this is looking at
the presence or at
it's not looking at the presence or
absence of the signal
but looking at the relative location of
two signals to determine whether a gene
is still intact or if it has broken
apart
ihc is looking at protein expression it
identifies the presence of a protein
or a portion of the protein that is
targeted by the antibody in the tissue
in the case of alk rearrangement the
target would be the tyrosine kinase
portion of the protein
in pcr amplification we can identify
genetic variation to the single
nucleotide level
making it a great technology for
identifying gene mutations
or gene rearrangements if the exact
location where the arrange
rearrangement occurs is already known
and while the alkfish assay was chosen
as the companion diagnostic
for pfizer's del quarry due to the fact
that ihc and r2pcr
missed some of the positive cases during
the clinical trials
efforts continue into the improvement of
ihc assays
in order to match fish capabilities
many studies were conducted using
several antibody clones for the alk
protein
you um with the outcome that nova castra
the 5a4 clone and the ventana b5f3 clone
were selected as optimal choices to
match
fish capabilities in 2016
an analysis by jang and associates was
performed on 12 different studies
which evaluated testing methods with
almost 4
000 non-small cell lung cancer specimens
in locations throughout the world
they concluded that using ihd to screen
non-small cell lung cancer cases
was a cost-effective method when a
four-tier scoring system
such as that recommended by novacaster
584 outcasts with you
where the oneplus and two-plus results
would then be reflexed to alk fish
analysis for confirmatory testing
the outcome of their data along with
further analysis
which adds several other studies to this
assessment
allows us an overall assessment of the
sensitivity
and specificity of the two antibody
clones as compared to fish
finding that in most cases ihc was
either not as
sensitive or as specific as fish
methodology
taking a further look at the
fda-approved ihc test
demonstrates that even in their studies
conducted specifically for fda approval
of the vantana d5f3ip assay
did not reach the 95 agreement
to the fda approved fish test
this range in concordance observed with
ihc
could be due to several factors as
mentioned by aruta and minas newton
when it comes to ihc to identify
alkaline arrangements
there are risks of false positive and
false negative results
caused by the relatively low expression
levels of rearranged alk
in non-small cell lung cancer thus
requiring amplification systems
to enhance alk detection and the
morphological features of the tumor
that may interfere with those
amplification systems
there's also the inherent lack of assay
quality controls
when it comes to ihc and with the two
leading clone manufacturers there is no
standardized method
for assay assessment where the
interpretation associated with using the
d5 f3 clone
is significantly different from that of
the 5a4 clone
while fish methodology has been
associated with difficulties
due to pre-analytical method variability
and the need for experienced
technologies
technologists these same factors can be
attributed to ihc methodology
therefore consideration should be taken
interpreting ihc results with caution
and employing confirmation by fish could
be beneficial when facing challenging
cases
overall when comparing fish to ihc
and identifying alka-gene rearrangements
the following factors can be considered
both are slide-based systems requiring
similar sample processing methodologies
such as sample fixation and paraffin
embedding
and even placing the tissue samples on
the slide
when it comes to fda approval or other
regulatory body approval
the fish assay is fda approved
and ce marked and
the ventana alka d5f3
cdf assay is also fda approved
while the nova castro clone 5a4
ce marked assay is only approved
it's only ce marked not fd approved
when it comes to the special equipment
required
for those assays there is a requirement
of having a fluorescent microscope to
perform
fish analysis as well as an automated
slide warmer can be beneficial
the ventana bond max is required
equipment to perform ihc using the d5f3
clone
while novacaster does not have any such
requirements
at the same time the automated side
processor
is an option when performing fish
methodology
when it comes to training requirements
to perform these assays
fish does require the training on
special taps
on recognizing special signal patterns
and
the cutoff of the assay while vantana
has an interpretation guide to assist
pathologists
in understanding the different types of
staining patterns that can be observed
and whether or not they would be
positive or negative while novocaster
relies on the standard intensity level
assessments
of zero to three plus and when it comes
to establishing
result reporting requirements such as
scoring and cutoff levels
the fish assay comes with a specific 15
positive out of 50 tumor cells as a
scoring requirement for a positive case
while this is for ihc based on
processing and signal detection
amplification systems
with the two clones where ventana relies
on a positive negative system
based on the interpretation guide and
nova castro relies on the zero through
four
plus through three plus intensity
staining level
even recommending to confirm with
another method
when the results are one plus or two
plus
interestingly enough differences between
these methodologies for identifying roth
1 gene rearrangement
have been more clear cut fish has
historically been considered
the gold standard in identifying cross-1
gene rearrangement
again this technology does not require
knowledge of the fusion partner when
using
break apart probes and it can be
performed on formal and fixed paraffin
embedded and phytology specimens
but when it comes to ihc since ros1 is
normally expressed in multiple tissues
using ihc becomes more challenging than
other assays associated with fusion
proteins
as this methodology may not be able to
distinguish between normal expression
and increased expression due to
amplification versus gene rearrangement
an assessment by pal and can of multiple
studies
comparing ihc to fish for ross 1 showed
variability in the results
they found that detection systems the
antigen retrieval methodologies and
staining conditions affect
outcome along with a variability of
scoring systems
and in most studies demonstrated a high
sensitivity but a variable specificity
therefore ihc has been presented as
applicable for pre-screening purposes
with a follow-up with confirmatory fish
testing
looking back at the guidelines we can
see that there have been continued
developments in the treatments of
non-small cell lung cancer
between the 2018 cap iislc
and amp updated guidelines which added
roth1 generate arrangements to be
considered
part of the absolute minimum primary
biomarkers to be tested
on patients with appropriate non-small
cell lung cancer profiles
this was due to the fact that brock 1
was shown to also be a target for
alzheimer's and kinase inhibitors
the specific guidelines on the
appropriate methodology stated that
egfr mutation should be tested by pcr
methods
lost one gene rearrangements are to be
performed by
fish testing and out gene rearrangements
are to be tested using
fish rearrangement probes and they added
a properly validated ihc method
as an acceptable alternative to fish
testing
this was if the evidence supporting the
use of ihc was
adequate and when the ihc results are
clearly positive
but challenging to interpret cases
should still be followed up with another
test
such as fish at the same time the
guidelines included
using multiplex genetic sequencing
panels for next generation sequencing
they introduced this methodology as the
preferred option
to identify other treatments beyond
those of egfr
alk and ros1 the following year
the national comprehensive cancer
network added braf mutation analysis to
the list of primary molecular biomarker
analysis
with a methodology guideline similar to
those presented by cap
islc and app they also included
the fda-approved ihc ventana d5f3
cbx assay and they recommended
broader molecular profiling using ngs
but did not advocate any specific
assay stating that not all alterations
can be detected
in a single mgs assay
this year nccn added net exon skipping
and rhett g and rearrangements to the
growing list of key molecular biomarkers
that should be tested
still encouraging the use of broader
molecular profiling
but again not advocating for any
specific test
while cautioning on the choice of assay
since not all alterations can be
detected by the individual tests
implying that there may be a need to
perform more than one
ngs assay to answer all questions
so what should we know about ngs testing
this is a high throughput method
that performs simultaneous sequencing of
multiple targets
in multiple samples it starts out with a
library
of dna fragments is created these
fragments are then amplified and
sequenced
the sequencing software analyzes the
fragment sequences
creating larger constructs and the
constructs are further analyzed by
bioinformatics software
comparing them to known or normal
sequences
this methodology is associated with a
wide breadth of applications
the genome sequencing can be performed
whole exome sequencing
cdna sequencing and gene expression
profiling can be performed using ngs
as well as methylation sequencing and
mapping and many more applications are
available
this mgs provides the ability to
identify genetic alterations on a much
larger scale thus driving advances in
clinical research
ngos started at the academic and
research setting and it has been
entering the clinical field over the
past several years developing in private
institutions
and it has even been growing in the
community-based practices
in one study use of ngs in the clinical
setting would seem to increase at a
community-based practice
by approximately 15 percent in five
years
and it continues to grow as mentioned
earlier numerous ngs assays for research
youth
only have been validated in laboratories
with variations
in the sensitivity and specificity the
amount of dna required
the percent of tumor tissue needed the
limit of detection and the sex fast rate
but in the clinical setting ngs can
provide information on targetable
mutations
and direct patients with limited
therapeutic options
into clinical trials with a high
complexity of this technology though
chances for variability are also high
which has led to a measured
implementation
as a quick overview of the general
complexity of a methodology
we can be seen here with the
acknowledgement that it is continuously
developing
technology it requires multiple steps
and multiple days starting with
nucleotide isolation
followed by target enrichment where
different methodologies
can specifically identify the areas
of research or testing
such as hybrid capture or amplicon pcr
when specific targets are amplified for
further sequencing
once this is completed library
construction is
performed where these targets are
appropriately labeled
and then nasa's parallel sequencing
ensues
followed by comprehensive data analysis
relying on bioinformatics algorithms
which can be experimental and
dependence on the russian sequences and
whether they are public or proprietary
databases
many quality checks are required
throughout this workflow
there are of course advantages to using
ngs in the clinical setting
benefits such as expanding options and
providing more information on initial
tumor
profiling and therapy management
adoption in the clinical laboratory
setting has been increasing
especially with the limitation of tissue
available and the increasing list
of molecular targets providing
therapeutic guidance
increasing demand for the uncut as well
as increasing demand from the oncologist
and the patient
the clinical utility is increasing as
target enrichment and improved
methodologies
decreased time to result what initially
started
as several weeks is decreasing to
several days
but there are of course drawbacks
extensive information including
is included with results of undetermined
clinical significance thus being
criticized for
for providing clinician results would be
beyond those that are actionable there's
also limited capabilities in identifying
gene rearrangements
using targeted enrichment requires prior
knowledge
of the potential fusion partners while
higher assay complexity and lower
success rate
has been also a factor based on the
availability and the quality of
sequencing data often due to processing
issues
the longer time to result and higher
costs can also be problematic
when patients are waiting on treatment
decisions and there may be a risk of not
getting insurance coverage
and when it comes to gene rearrangements
specifically without
having more than 50 potential fusion
partners involved one having more than
25
standard ngs is unlikely to identify
novel or rare rearrangements
if not performing rna and gs
as mentioned earlier there is a growing
number of laboratories bringing ngs
in-house
with variation in methodology and assay
parameters
therefore when it comes to using ngs
specifically to identify out gene
rearrangements
i will focus on the three assays that
have received fda approval or
authorization
the msk impact foundation 1 cds
and the oncoming dx assays
the um the msk impact
astate looks at over 300 genes
but only the eml for alk translocation
it is also an institution specific assay
that requires sending of the sample to
memorial zone kettering the fda-approved
oncoming dx assay is
produced by thermal fish or scientific
and is available
for laboratories to purchase an
implement but it has
no claim in the us for alpha gene
rearrangement
while the fda approved foundation 1 cdf
assay
also an institution-specific assay
showed only 92 accuracy for positive
outcases
compared to fda approved fish and ihd
tests combined
compared to fish nitrate sensitivity ngs
assays have been seen to be as low as 80
percent
with the expected limitations of less
common rearrangements
similarly to alk depending on ngs method
used
the exact known fusion partners of roth1
may be identified
using rna as a starting material may
provide more information
depending on the assay design there are
multiple examples where a unique fusion
partner was identified in only one
patient's sample
usually through whole genome sequencing
and this is a very good methodology for
research purposes and clinical trial
stratification
but the sample quality and quantity is
even more critical
for successful rna mgs results
as mentioned the higher failure rate
that has been associated with ngs
could be a significant factor when it
comes to choosing the appropriate
methodology
and as can be seen here in a study that
evaluated
fish compared to rna mgs and dna ingest
it is significant to note that rna mgs
showed a 47 failure rate
based on the quality parameters and
overall ability to obtain
a significant amounts of rna
diagnosing patients with non-small cell
lung cancer requires a histological
assessment of the
tumor and the continued efforts to have
minimally invasive procedures
and reduce patient discomfort lead to
the diagnosis commonly being performed
on fine needle aspirate or corneal
biopsies
therefore careful considerations need to
be taken of the methodologies employed
with the critical amounts of sample
available
while fish and ihc are slide based with
specific number of slides required to
perform the assay
already being established generally two
for fish
and three for ihd or one of those sides
as an h and e
side to determine the area of tumors ngs
requirements for successful tests become
more limiting they are based on the
quality of the extracted nucleotides
the amount of extracted nucleotides the
size of the tissue and the percent of
tumor necessary
is also a significant factor when
determining the number of slides
necessary for successful ngs results
the swami and associates estimated that
the number of slides
of paraffin-embedded tissue required for
successful ngs
could range from one when there is a
large tumor with a
percentage on a large tissue to more
than 10
up to 20 depending on the size and
percent of tumor present
and when the number of actionable
mutations is expanding
the amount of tissue collected is not
pathologists are now increasingly
required to exercise
caution in specimen processing
conservation of tissue and biomarker
test selection to ensure
that actionable information can be
provided
it is therefore interesting to note
whether or not
with the risk of unsuccessful ngs it is
worth
using a large amount of tissue to
determine
those results or pulling off a couple of
slides
for fish or ihc
the other aspect to be considered is
that the progressive nature of non-small
cell lung cancer demands
swift therapeutic response targeted
therapeutic selection relies on
knowledge of patients genetic
alterations thus driving a critical need
for timely results cap iasoc and amp
allotted 10 days between sample receipt
and reporting of results
a 2017 assessment of real-world clinical
practice
showed that 34 of patients tested for
out rearrangements
had results delayed by more than four
weeks it was a possibility that only 42
percent of those patients received
appropriate therapy
in many cases the time to obtain ngs
results
may take longer than two weeks extensive
computer analysis and pathologist
interpretation occurs only after the
initial sequence analysis
thus delaying things even further even
with technology continuing to advance
and reduce the time to results
meeting those recommendations can be
challenging for laboratories forwarding
samples
to centralized testing laboratories or
performing
in-house ngs risk of potentially
delaying the placement of patients into
proper
treatment protocols is continues
so is ngs the best option in identifying
alkanross one gene rearrangement
detecting break points using dna and gs
can be brought problematic breakpoints
often occur in intron regions that can
be difficult to sequence due to high
gc content dna and gs also requires
prior knowledge of rearrangement
partners
rna ngs heavily relies on the quality of
rna
limited when extracted from ffp tumor
samples
some ngs assays rely on expression of
imbalances between three prime and five
prime portions of the gene to determine
gene rearrangements but they are
assuming that the difference in
expression is due to a rearrangement
enough
and not any other factors
so which methodology is the appropriate
choice
prior to the 2018 guidelines egfr and
elf were the only two molecular
biomarkers recommended for non-small
cell lung cancer testing
and most out-testing algorithms used
involves
using either fish or ihc methodology and
many including both
at some stage fish testing has high
sensitivity and specificity
that does not depend on gene fusion
partners or
kinase activity to demonstrate gene
rearrangement
the probe design is critical in making
sure that the
more difficult rearrangements can still
be identified
iht testing has come close to matching
the sensitivity and specificity of fish
the potential need to confirm results
with fish for negative or challenging
cases still
remain while ngs provides an array of
genomic information
it is not always clinically actionable
it is however beneficial in treatment
selection
or when seeking clinical trials lacking
in
the level of sensitivity and specificity
compared to fischer isd for the
detection of gene rearrangements
ngs also takes a longer time to result
and can delay patient
treatment therefore the question remains
if the risks of invalidated outcomes and
lower success rate
are worth risking exhausting the sample
prior to obtaining successful and
actionable results
again the best course of action could be
that there are advantages and
disadvantages of each technology
ideally molecular laboratories would
have the means to employ all the methods
without any limitations
most important to take into
consideration is the patient's health
and the limitations set on the available
methodologies
the time it requires they require the
sample availability
the effects of workflow based on the
assay complexities
whether these affect the success rate of
the assay
and the cost in reimbursement using a
single test for all the answers is an
appealing concept
but should the critical biomarkers that
provide answers to actionable targets
be prioritized and not risked
so what do we believe is the best course
of action
with the current limitations of ngs
testing
fish and ihc have an advantage as
preferred methods
specifically when it comes to
identifying alk and roth1 gene
rearrangements
however the overall path of testing for
non-small cell lung cancer patients
can encompass all the previously
mentioned technologies
where each has a role in the patient
care life cycle
beginning with the initial diagnosis of
non-small cell lung cancer
which relies on imaging like radiography
and histological evaluation using h e
staining
and various ihcms assays
followed by prognostic as well as
predictive evaluation
to identify the optimal treatment using
ihc
fish pcr and even ngs
with ngs playing a bigger role later
when monitoring the response to
treatment
or searching for options for the
refractory or relapse patients
as we discussed earlier the non-small
cell lung cancer genomic testing
standards are expanding
and evolving rapidly those involved in
the patient care journey the
laboratories and the clinicians
must be cautious when selecting new
technologies diagnostic approaches and
therapy
laboratories must ensure the quality and
consistency of the methods employed
when providing clinicians with
actionable results
identifying gene rearrangements such as
alk and roth 1 can still be challenging
depending on the methodology employed
fish is still an appropriate option
either as a standalone pest or in
combination with ihc
reflexing to fish for borderline or
difficult cases
while ngs may one day become the primary
test method replacing others such as
fission ic
fish can still enable laboratories to
provide
prompt and accurate and cost-effective
results thus facilitating the treatment
decisions that allow patients to achieve
the best possible outcomes in the
disease that has been considered to have
a very poor prognosis
and with that i would like to thank you
very much for attending
and please submit your questions and i
will be happy to answer them
thank you yelina for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
of your questions
as we have time for so let's get started
elena the first question i have for you
do all
ngs applications use libraries
that's a really good question and i
thank you for asking that
in reality the technology is always
advancing and the answer is
no however those assays that are
currently ongoing that do not create
ngs libraries and go straight from the
dna
or rna that has been isolated are
still in research laboratories
and are still being developed and
optimized so when it comes to the
clinical application of
ngs libraries are a
significant benefit and often are
even optimized specifically for the
tumor
just providing targeted tumor profiles
for patients
awesome thank you elena the next
question i have
are there ngs applications that could
identify gene rearrangements without
prior knowledge of potential fusion
partners
there are of course those applications
with whole
genome sequencing you would be able to
identify
any fusion that has occurred however
whole genome sequencing
takes longer and requires more
incoming dna samples
at the same time as i mentioned in the
presentation
rna sequencing is an option
but rna requires a more a higher quality
of sample and is more sensitive
to processing
and those are just two examples
wonderful it looks like we have time for
about one more question do you foresee
ngs
ever being the primary methodology used
to assess
molecular abnormalities
um i do but just not right now
i foresee that being an aspect maybe in
five years
but right now even outside of non-small
cell lung cancer when evaluating
any type of samples whether it's
hematology or
tumor tissue there is always a need
to follow up or there is always an
aspect where
the ngs results are just not quite there
and do not provide
all the information available therefore
it is still necessary to include other
methodologies to identify
gene abnormalities especially when it
comes to gene rearrangement
thank you again elena for your time
today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor abbott
scientific affairs molecular diagnostics
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided
at the time of your registration lab
routes will alert you
via email when this webinar is available
for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time stay healthy
goodbye
you